hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over the bishop gambit which is
one of the more common lines in the
Kings gambit accepted line and that is e
4 e 5 F 4 here giving up pawn material
here on the F 4 square and then Bishop
to c4 now the most common line in the
Kings gambit is Knight to f3 this is my
favorite opening in chess but Bishop to
c4 is also a very good opening line from
white now a lot of times players aren't
playing this because they don't like the
fact that the Queen can immediately come
here to h4 forcing the King to f1 why
it's not gonna be able to castle on the
King side and they usually like to
castle bring their rook here to f1 and
then use the rook in the attack
specifically on this semi open F file
the main difference in the bishop gamete
compared to the normal King's gambit
accepted line with Knight here to f3 is
the bishop is gonna be doing all the
attacking instead of this rook from h1
so if you're a player that likes the
Kings gambit but you also like to attack
with your bishop this is going to be a
good variation for you so we're gonna be
going over the main lines that you'll
see one is if the Queen comes here to h4
also if you see Knight to f6 or Knight
to c6 or if you see something like d6
opening up for the LightSquared bishop
to get involved we're gonna be going
over all of those variations in the
Bishop's gambit the first raishin that
we're gonna look at is if the Queen
comes down here to h4 King to f1 but
just know that eventually why it's gonna
play Knight to f3 that is going to force
this black queen here on h4 to move
white really wants to get as much
material involved into the game and
control the center with the pawns as
quickly as possible and just let black
have to worry about having no center
control no minor piece is really
involved to the game and their Queens
gonna be being chased all over the board
you typically don't want to have your
pieces move around a lot especially in
the beginning of the game and you
usually don't want to have your Queen
just hanging out here on the h-file if
it has nothing else to attack so yes
white does have a King here on f1 that's
not doing too much
blocking off the rook on h1 but why
definitely has a lot of attacking lines
in this now depending on what black does
you're typically not gonna see d5
because usually the queen is back here
on da protecting that because now you
can just snag that with your Bishop
right here but you could see d6 so
putting up for the LightSquared Bishop
you get involved into the game but as we
talked about Knight to f3 forcing the
Queen back Queen really has three
options it could come to h5 come here to
h6 can't come to g5 would get captured
by the knight here or it could come back
to f6e 7 doesn't make a lot of sense
blocking off the dark square bishop and
then coming back to d8 why even bring
the Queen out if you're gonna just bring
it back to d8 so you could come up or
you could see h6 here in this case
you're gonna play d4 again controlling
the turn of the board opening up for
more material to get involved into the
game Bishop takes on f4 at some points
protected by the Queen right now but you
will be able to get this material back
white typically does not stay down in
material very long Knight to c3 not
really trying to control the center of
the board now once they once you play
this before let's say they play c6 okay
c3 here makes a lot of sense if they
play Knight to f6 at this point because
d4 is here we can start to push forward
with E 5 if they take here do not
recapture with your pawn it may look
good and say okay yeah this is pretty
good I'm attacking the Knights right
here but once they come down here to h5
actually they can protect this pawn and
this is a pretty good setup on the King
side of the board and then how does
white really continue it's gonna be
better for White's perspective if they
take with their night here on e5 because
this threatens the attack here on f7 and
it's very very difficult for black to
hold on and control this King side of
the board without giving something up
the really the only option they have is
to play Bishop to e6
and then the bishop can take here the
pawn takes here and then Queen to f3 now
both the Queen and the bishop are attack
in the pond the Queen is attacking
this pawn here on the seven which is no
longer defended by the LightSquared
Bishop so this is gonna be a very good
variation for white now the next
variation you may see instead of the
Queen coming to h6 is Queen to h5 why
it's gonna same game plan
d4 here now this pawn on f4 is no longer
protected so why it's gonna have an
easier job taking this material back and
have very very aggressive bishops in the
center of the board now if you see
Knight to c6 same thing as before Knight
to c3 here one slight thing to keep in
mind is if they play g5 they could just
go all out on the King side of the board
here then Knight to d5 is difficult to
deal with one if white ever wanted to
has both the knight and the bishop
attacking this pawn right here so he
could just have an exchange and blow up
the King side of the board but also it's
now threatening this pawn here on c7
which would be a fork to the king and
the rook here so something else that's
gonna be very difficult for black to
have to deal with if they instead play
instead of Knight to c6 they could come
up here and played Knight to f6 same
thing you're gonna play c3 Knight to c3
main difference here is if they play g5
then you're gonna push forward with E 5
attacking the Knights right here again
if they exchange you can bring your
knight up here that's going to be good
for whites if instead they say yeah I
don't want to bring my knight involved
maybe I just want to play g5 from here
White's gonna play h4 a little bit
different not getting your knight
involved you need to counter attack
right away and then if they push forward
with g4 then you have the nice move of
Knight to g5 it has an outpost here with
the pawn on h4 this is very similar to
the mainline in the King's gambit
without even bringing the bishop you
bring a knight here to f3 and then here
to g5 and then you can see very very
difficult from plaque to hold on control
it's even worse if they now bring their
Bishop to e6 because after the exchange
then the knight can take here on e6
attacking the pawn here for king the
king and the rook there's just no good
squares for black to move to the Kings
sides pretty weak in the Queen here on
h5 is not doing anything and none of the
other material is involved into the game
and white has control the center of the
board also is threatening the bishop
coming to f4 and capturing more material
so this is also going to be very very
good for white the last place you may
see the Queen come to is f6 it does keep
it very active White's still gonna play
d4 it's protected by the knight and the
Queen right here but this queen is
awkwardly placed it blocks the knight
coming here to f6 and it's not really
threatening anything from white now from
here if Knight to c6 same thing from
White Knight to c3 right here if instead
maybe they played Bishop down to g4
pinning down the knight right here
that's fine I would still continue with
Knight to c3 this is not a big threat
the black has right here and then
eventually depending on where black goes
white also has some variations where if
the Queen's not here you could play
Bishop takes on f7 check and then the
knight can come up here to g5 after the
King takes here on f7 again can't do
that right now with the Queen on f6 but
there are some options the White has
later on in the board state if they
decide instead to play Bishop to e6 go
ahead and take right here once the pawn
takes then you could play Queen to d2
this now puts both the Queen and the
bishop attacking this pawn here on f4 so
that's what happens if they play the
Queen down to h4 early on check the King
again you can see from all those
variations yes the rook had never got
involved into the game like typically in
the mainline the King's gambit accepted
but the King was completely safe and
white had a lot of variations where they
were attacking especially with that
light squared bishop I do wanna go Bert
one variation that you will see beyond
that d6 because I have seen it played
quite a few times as I was testing this
out and that is the knight coming
to f6 now I call this out specifically
because it could be tempting after you
see Knight f6 to just push forward with
E 5 that is not the game plan other
openings absolutely you want to be
pushing but the Queen here on h4 adds a
different dimension to the game because
Knight down to g4 putting a lot of
pressure on this King side obviously
this is going to be checkmate down here
if white tries to stop it with Queen to
e1 you could have check right here
there's no good options you take you're
gonna lose the material here on h2 and
you can see King can't Castle kingside
completely obliterated then you're gonna
see moves like Bishop to c5 this is very
very bad so if they do play Knight to f6
the move is going to be Knight to f3
forcing the Queen back now if the Queen
comes to h6 same thing as before
d4 also keep in mind if they try
something sneaky like Knight takes on e4
now you can play Queen to e2 and they're
going to lose this material let's say
Knight to f5 trying to hold down this
material
okay well Knight to c3 and they're not
going to be able to stop this you can
take the knight even if they respond you
can take that material back here on e4
other option that you could see if
instead they play Queen to h5 here same
thing
d4 now the big difference is if they
play Queen takes on e4 and you play
Queen to e2 now they can actually defend
with d5 before they couldn't their Queen
was here on h6 and it was not defending
this pawn but now it actually is
defending the material that's fine I
would still play Knight to c3 yes you
were giving up in this bishop but if
they take that bishop on c4 they're
gonna have a pretty difficult setup
you're gonna take their night here on e4
so they take your minor piece you take
theirs after the King moves
you're gonna take with your bishop on f4
and look at all the material you have in
the center of the board you can swing
rook over here they have no material
involved their queen on h5 is not doing
a heck of a lot and you have a very very
strong attack now if we come back to the
very beginning of the Bishop's gambit
you could see Knight to f6 early on
instead of the Queen coming out here and
I just mentioned that yes you typically
don't want to be playing pawn up here to
e5 and I would again recommend you don't
play e5 I just think there's better
moves that you can do in this opening
you really want to get more material
involved into the game so I would still
continue with the game plan of Knight to
c3 now if they play something like d6
because this is extremely common
especially in the Kings gambit to open
up the door for the light square bishop
but also recognizing they may not have
controlled the center so d6 makes a lot
of sense d4 if they play something like
Bishop to d7 getting ready to castle on
the Kings side this pawn here on f4 is
unprotected you can take it you can see
how different that is than if the Queen
is over here it's protecting the pawn
but none of these pieces are actually
defending that material you can just
take back and you have a good game you
can still castle your King on the king's
heads is they never brought their Queen
down to attack that if instead they play
Bishop down to g4 okay that's fine
Knight to f3 getting ready to castle on
the Kings side you don't even care if
they take you can recapture with your
queen and then take the pawn here on f4
you have that option as well if instead
they get their Knight involved so Knight
to c6 sure go ahead and take with your
Bishop here on f4 now instead of d6 the
main difference here is they can
actually play d5 because the Queen is
still protecting this whereas before the
Queen was here on h4 it was not
controlling the center of the board but
if they do see this I would go ahead and
take with your Knights I don't like to
lose my bishop you can absolutely take
with your bishop but I like to keep my
bishop open to attack this weekend
square here on f7 later on into the game
if they go ahead and take right here at
this point now you can go ahead and take
with your Bishop if you want to since
they don't have immediate threats that
are attacking this right here
if we come back let's say they decide to
try something crazy Knight takes on e4
well now you can play Queen to e2 it's
gonna be very difficult to hold on to
this knife now if they play f5 you can
just play d3 you're going to be taking
this material right here they can't move
this Knight because it's pinned down to
the Queen right here they're gonna lose
their night so they can't do that
they're pretty much gonna have to take
the night here on d5
now instead of d5 you could see the move
c6 and this sets up for black pushing
forward with d5 they're trying to
control the center of the board
but that's our game that's what we're
trying to do so we're just gonna push
forward say if yeah you could try that
but we're gonna play a d4 right here now
if they play d5 because that's what
they're setting up for in that case I
would just go ahead and take the
material if they recapture I would play
Bishop to b5 right here check after they
played Knight to c6 boom take material
here with your Bishop on f4 you have a
very aggressive board sit you can get
your queen of all into the game you can
castle on the Queen side you can still
play Knight to f3 castle on the Kings
side so don't let them play that c6
nonsense and try to control the center
white can still control the center even
if they do that instead of bringing
their knight to f6 they could bring
their knight to c6 white same game plan
d4 what I like about the bishops gambit
like some other openings it's consistent
you don't have to memorize too many
things it's the concept of how White's
trying to approach the game trying to
get all their Knights coming here to f3
or c3 then get your Bishop here to f4
play d4 control the center of the board
and always be looking to attack squares
like f7 same game plan doesn't matter
where they really go to so Knight to c6
you're gonna come up here to d4 if they
want to now bring their queen down to h4
that's fine check we've been through
this before
the King comes to f1 this is a similar
setup as before you can just see if they
come here first you're gonna play this
and then they play Knight to c6 d4
this is completely fine now if they play
Knight to f6 you already guessed it
we're gonna play Knight to f3 here
forcing the Queen back maybe Queen to h6
Knight to c7 very similar moves as we've
seen before if the Queen doesn't come up
maybe they want to play the two Knights
game and get Knight to f6 here Knight to
c3 no reason to play Knight to f3 you
don't have to force the Queen away right
here so Knight to c3 if they try to pin
this this material down it is important
to play Knight to e2 you want to both
attack this material as well as bring
your knight here if they do decide to
play Bishop takes on c3 so very
important to keep in mind on that one
now at the very beginning they don't
have to play their knights to c6 either
but there's not a lot of other options
that I think are viable for black if you
see something like d6 early on doesn't
really get any minor pieces involved
into the game I don't really like this
too much from black but you could see it
Knight to f3 here just stopping the
Queen from ever coming down here because
this sets it up for me at least to
castle on the King side on the next move
if you want to if they now try to pin
down material you could just play d4
controlling the center of the board same
thing is if they play something like
Knight to c6 you could play d4
controlling that's fine as well but that
is the Bishop's gambit from the King's
gambit accepted line so if you do like
to play the King's game and hopefully
you do since it's my favorite opening in
chess and you play a lot of the knight
to f3 go ahead and try out the bishops
game but let me know what you guys think
I've had a lot of fun playing it myself
but until next time thank you guys for
watching I'll see you in the next video